hallo leute heute zeigen wir euch einige
kabel rund um das radfahren und die
fahrradreparatur denn wir machen mein
fahrrad fit für den sommer und dazu
haben uns einen experten dazu geholt
los geht's
[Musik]
und dieser experte von dem ich gerade
gesprochen habe ist mein vater hallo ich
bin die der fahrradexperte wir sind hier
in der garage meines vaters in den
heiligen hallen wo er an seinem motorrad
schraubt an autos an fahrrädern an so
ziemlich allem und er wird heute mir
dabei helfen mein fahrrad fit für den
sommer zu machen
los geht's und falls ihr euch wundert
wie wir während der korona pandemie so
ein video drehen alles auf distanz ja
hier ist meine werkzeug box in dieser
werkzeug box sind die werkzeuge um
dieses fahrrad zu reparieren
da haben wir alles um die entsprechenden
reparaturen durchzuführen
am fahrrad haben wir die reflektoren der
vorderreifen das vorder licht das
körbchen die klingel die handbremse die
gangschaltung der rahmen die pedalen
der sattel der gepäckträger das
hinterrad und das rücklicht
ja ich zeige euch jetzt die werkzeuge
mit denen wir das fahrrad überprüfen
mit dieser zange werden wir die bremsen
einstellen
mit diesem schlüssel werden wir die
pedale festziehen das ist ganz wichtig
die können nämlich auch abfallen die
pedale
mit diesem schlüssel werden wir das
vorderrad fest ziehen und das hinterrad
lösen um die kette nachspannen zu können
mit diesem uralten schlüssel kann man
den sattel verstellen und was das ist ah
das ist glaube ich die luftpumpe um die
reifen aufzupassen ja es ist hier bin
ich mir jetzt ganz sicher ja ich sie
überprüft mal die speicher nicht kaputt
brechen nicht so fest nur leicht drücken
isabel jetzt stellen wir die bremse ein
das werkzeug hast du ja schon hast du
musst aufpassen das ist
dadurch gleich was ab gefühlvoll ja so
ist gut so ist ja noch mal nachstellen
noch etwas nachstellen
ja so ist okay ja so können was lassen
so isabel jetzt stellen wir mit dem 15
der schüssel die pedalen nach bzw wir
schrauben sie fest die müssen ganz fest
seit ich das ist mir früher schon mal
passiert dass die pedalen ab verhalten
gefahren das ist ganz saugefährlich ja
jetzt sind wir dabei die kette
nachzustellen
die ist nämlich ziemlich wacklig die
kette isabel hat die schrauben schon
gelöst
jetzt ziehen wir das rad nach hinten und
jetzt ja so ist gut so sieht's gut aus
jetzt kannst du die schrauben wieder
fest rehn isabel ja sehr gut nicht zu
fest aber handfest
ja das sieht gut aus so lassen wir das
sowieso welt hat sich jetzt die zange
genommen
die engländer genannt wird diese zahl
wird in deutschland tatsächlich
engländer genannt ich weiß nicht warum
und mit diesem engländer stellt isabell
jetzt sattel er sollte etwas höher
eingestellt werden
der jurist die schraube das ist schon
gut erzählt sattel etwas hochziehen und
jetzt die schraube wieder mit dem
engländer festzunehmen
jetzt wollen wir noch den luftdruck
korrigieren
die reifen sehen ziemlich glatt aus
dieser welt dann kommt mal das fahrrad
auf die reifen vorn und hinten
es wird der kraft genug für israel das
wirst du wohl schaffen okay dann komme
ich meine halbe stunde wieder
dann bist du fertig haben beim aufbau ja
sie macht das schon ganz gut wir treffen
uns dann gleich wieder ja alles super
glaubt wir sind fertig wir machen zwei
jahren keine sorge sie das kriegen wir
schon hin wohl erstmal 24
ich habe alles schon fertig gemacht der
stolze
wir können schon los war
so das war mein fahrrad repariert und
fit für den sommer
wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr vokabeln lernen
wollt dann probiert doch mal unsere app
sieht länger aus dort könnt ihr unter
anderem auch euren aussprache trainieren
ihr nehmt euch selbst auf und vergleicht
oder aussprache dann mit der eines
mutter sprach lassen so könnte schritt
für schritt eure aussprach verbessern
bis bald
[Musik]